so one of the studies i saw recently was
about vitamin c
and recovery this was a meta-analysis so
vitamin c it's a well-known antioxidant
we've talked about antioxidants on the
show quite a bit in the past
very common thought here is that
high-dose vitamin c supplementation
will reduce oxidative stress and
inflammation caused by training
and theoretically this would improve
recovery and performance
and so the idea is if you're training
like crazy
and you're causing all this oxidative
stress and inflammation if you could
take this vitamin c
it would attenuate some of that mitigate
some of that so you could get back into
the gym earlier
and train harder because of those
theoretical recovery benefits so
recent meta-analysis put this theory to
the test they looked at the effect
of vitamin c supplementation on lipid
peroxidation and that's
indicative of oxidative stress they also
looked at interleukin-6 or il-6 which is
a marker of inflammation
they looked at creatine kinase they
looked at c-reactive protein
cortisol they also looked at soreness
and strength recovery
after uh some pretty intense exercise
bouts so what they
found here cutting right to the results
um
there was a small reduction in lipid
peroxidation
and il-6 in response to vitamin c
supplementation and again this is
a meta-analysis so they looked at
several studies that that all looked at
those particular outcomes
what's interesting though so so starting
out you think okay well that supports
the theory right we're going to reduce
oxidative stress
inflammation that's going to improve all
these different aspects of recovery
what's really interesting is that the
other outcomes were not significantly
impacted
uh in a meaningful way and so what we
saw there is that
there were these ma these modest
reductions in markers of oxidative
stress and inflammation
however that didn't actually translate
over into the things we really care
about
as a lifter right so if you ask them are
you more sore or less sore
soreness was not impacted in a
meaningful way same thing when it comes
to the actual recovery of strength
performance
after those those intense exercise
sessions so
you know this is something that came up
in the antioxidant article that i wrote
a few months ago for stronger by science
and
you know we looked a little bit at some
of the research you know
there is some research indicating that
really high dose vitamin c could
theoretically
blunt hypertrophy to a small degree that
evidence is inconsistent and the effect
doesn't seem to be huge so
a lot of people are out there worried
about if i have too much vitamin c in my
diet is it going to hurt my gains
the answer is probably not and if it
does have an effect it's going to be
pretty small but but
the research there is pretty mixed um
but one of the things i brought up in
the article is
a good question would be why you why are
you doing this high
high dose vitamin c supplementation in
the first place because
what we see looking at the literature in
this meta-analysis kind of supports this
contention
is that while it might not necessarily
kill your gains there just doesn't seem
to be much of a good
reason to do it this perceived benefit
this idea that it's gonna
you know completely change your your
ability to adapt to training and get you
back in the gym
quicker and stronger it just doesn't
seem to pan out in the studies that
actually directly assess that question
so i'm still not convinced that you need
to worry
that if your vitamin c increases above a
certain threshold from food sources that
that's going to have any bearing on your
ability to grow in response to training
however i just don't see a really
compelling reason for a healthy
individual
to be using this high dose vitamin c as
a recovery aid
if you're interested in using some kind
of uh
some kind of antioxidant based
supplement for recovery
there's much better evidence for things
like tart cherry juice
you know there are some kind of
polyphenol based like
pomegranate blends and watermelon juice
blends that that have a bunch of other
active phytonutrients in them that seem
to have better effects on
actual recovery and even like turmeric
or yes curcumins curcuminoids
yeah yeah there are a lot of you know
uh a lot more of these kind of
phytonutrient
packed supplement blends that are based
on like i said you know
turmeric curcumin uh pomegranate
watermelon
tart cherry and they just seem to
perform better
in terms of the actual tangible recovery
parameters we care about
soreness and are you back to full
strength quicker
so if you want to go that direction and
you're interested
in some kind of antioxidant
supplementation
that might relate to enhanced blood flow
enhanced recovery something like that i
would encourage you to check out that
stronger by science article
stronger by science.com antioxidants i
go into some of the details
and one of the most important things
this is something came up in the betaine
article as well
whenever possible i try to recommend
dietary swaps
that would achieve the same effect
rather than
uh rather than you know buying a new
supplement and going out of your way and
spending a bunch of money so
when it comes to betaine i think there
are ways to get some more betaine into
your diet without necessarily buying a
supplement it takes a little bit of
effort
yeah there's some specific foods that
are pretty high in betaine
but the same thing goes with these
different antioxidant based approaches
to recovery
uh you know there are some foods that
that just deliver
a ton of antioxidants with a variety of
other phytonutrients just naturally
present in the food and so if you're
interested in seeing what some of those
foods are you can go to stronger by
science.com
antioxidants and check those out